well brian it was supposed to be a
location before the nfl draft
hundreds of people stepped foot inside
the caesars forum today
for the first time as they hosted their
first big meeting since
opening the space that was actually back
in march of 2020.
reporter victoria saha got to take a
sneak peek inside and she has our
report the caesars forum will not stay
silent any longer welcome everybody
michael masari with caesars
entertainment says tuesday was the first
time the new space
reopened its doors we've been dark here
mostly through the entire pandemic and
so now to have meeting professionals
international and 1200 people customers
that can book future meetings with us
we're really excited about back in 2020
the 375 million dollar conference center
had to close
right after opening because of the
pandemic it was also to be used as a
location for the nfl draft
and now they will make up for lost time
starting from this conference we go back
to back through the end of the year
conference attendees liked what they saw
and experienced it's absolutely gorgeous
it's exactly what i was expecting from
mpi so i'm glad to be here
i'm just excited that things are back to
live events we can all get together and
be in person the 550 thousand square
foot space can hold up to 10
thousand people victoria saha 8 news now
we can also tell you that the next event
at seizures forum is the american school
counselors association conference that's
coming up in july
and they'll be hosting about two
thousand guests
me